- So, do strangers,
I have this happen to
me sometimes in like,
the music world, but do
strangers come up to you
and just divulge the
weirdest things to you
because of "Curb Your Enthusiasm"?
- Yes! So, because "Curb" is this...
You know, sort of a commentary
on social graces and the lack thereof.
People come up to me and they
like to pitch shows to me.
So, I did this movie with Ray Romano,
we exchanged numbers
but we had never called
or texted each other so...
At the wrap party,
Ray wasn't there but this guy was like,
"I've got a great story for 'Curb'."
And I said, "Oh, okay."
- [Jesse] Oh.
(both laugh nervously)
- And so, I don't know how much I can say
on daytime television but so he--
- You can say it all we'll edit it out
when I hear it. (laughs)
- Okay, you'll beep it.
So, he says, "So, my wife
"and I were having
difficulty getting pregnant
"so I had to go give a sperm sample.
"So, I went to the doctor
"and there was no good porn
"and I was having trouble--
(Kelly laughs uproariously)
"and I wasn't allowed to
use lubricant so I was..."
And this isn't--
- You guys, I've literally been there.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh, are you?!
- [Jesse] This is like my story so far.
- Maybe we should do an episode!
- I love you right now!
- [Cheryl] Maybe we should!
- So far, so good.
- So, so far.
- Okay, keep going.
- So, he's telling me this story
with all these details and I--
- [Kelly] And he's a stranger!
- Never met him before in my life.
- Talking about his sperm!
- Yes!
- Go! Keep going.
- So, I said, "Uh, okay.
I got it, thank you.
"And I will tell Larry."
And he walked off and I
looked down at my phone
and for some reason my phone
had pocket dialed Ray Romano.
(Jesse gasps)
Who I had never talked
to on the phone before
and I said, "(gasps) Oh my gosh."
and I hung up and then
I looked to see how long
I had been connected to him
and it was like, five minutes.
So, then I start panicking and I'm like,
"Do I call Ray and tell him..."
and then my friend was like,
"Don't call, maybe he
didn't know it was you.
"Just let it lie."
And then the next morning,
like, first thing in the morning,
Ray Romano calls and he's like,
"Uh, did you call me in
the middle of the night?"
And I said, "Uh... I did,
"because the guy with the sperm
"and he didn't have
lube and then it was..."
(Kelly and audience laughs)
And I said, "And then I looked down
"and then I..." (laughs)
- Oh my god.
- "Then I looked down and
I was connected to you
and I said, 'Oh my gosh.'"
and he goes, "Yeah, I
didn't hear any of that."
- Oh! (laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh!
- And he said, "But, say it
again and slowly this time."
- Yeah, yeah! (laughs)
- And I was like, "Oh my." Anyways--
- 'Cause now he's gonna
use it for something.
- Yeah, exactly.
So, that was my first
phone call to Ray.
- What an epic butt dial!
- Yeah, I know!
- That is.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- That was awkward.
- It's such a Friends episode
with Monica Geller, I love it.
It's like, "I'm breezy! I was breezy."
- So good.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love that you chimed
in, "I've so been there."
- Literally.
- Best part of today.
(everyone laughs)
- I know!
You really connected with me.
- You guys, I mean, it's a process.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Okay.